Lois Lee reporting live from superhero
High School where a few of the students
took upon themselves to wreak havoc
throughout the campus never do something
like that
how could all three of us want remember
an entire day I can barely remember five
minutes ago was it fun
in everyone behold on mind-control
diamond again girls let's retrieve our
set from yesterday and find out who was
mind controlling act
oh man what didn't we just start with
that plan or we we needed the action
sequence I mean duh right hurry up
Sophie here stone stop right there
bumblebee katana you've got to stop
you're being controlled three out there
getting away let's stick together
I'll Drive back Dorothy then you should
really be using your blinker you were
saying only way to succeed is by working
together together
this rod must be red
there's nothing you can do to stop me
from destroying the earth if you can't
we'll see about that
Wonder Woman you take care of big ugly
over there
don't worry Batgirl I've got her ready
ready let's do this thing
little DC superhero girl brain-drain
look for it on DVD and digital